I have committed plenty of um Financial
infidelity trying to help my father
who's disabled um he has little to no
income so my fathers come to me for
loans um you know not we're not talking
like big numbers like thousands of
dollars or anything like that but you
know maybe in like the hundreds range um
but like we're my husband and I are kind
of like lowincome so it's a big deal
when we loan out you know a couple
hundred dollars a 100% of this is on
you yes I agree so what your dad is
doing what he knows to do which is to
ask you for money and he gets it from
you and so if you cut that off or if you
say Hey Dad it's not a good time he's
going to use whatever tactics he knows
and if he was on the phone I would say
stop doing that but the fact that he
gets an exchange money comes from your
account to him he he plays no part in
that